okay welcome back to another episode
it's chris again and today we're going
to find a date for nikki hi nikki you
are going to try three different
filipino dishes cooked by three
different guys and then you get to
decide who you are going to go on a date
with just based on those dishes sound
good sounds good i was born and raised
in the philippines specifically cousin
city but ever since i moved away and
started living on my own i actually
haven't been able to eat as much
filipino food as i want to so i'm really
excited for it today hopefully some of
the dishes remind me a little bit of how
my mom's cooking was hi i'm geo hey i'm
sam hi i'm jason how confident are you
that you're gonna win i got this in the
back i've already secured the bag i'm
just like looking at the dishes i'm
pretty confident i'm gonna lie not a
usual thing in my life but i'm pretty
confident i'm just gonna get stepped on
i know already
like in a good way or bad
[Music]
i made a mystic tagalog like beef loin
married with soy sauce a little bit of
vinegar and then some onions and garlic
i actually left everything to marinate
overnight and then i cooked it this
morning it's like super fresh as fresh
as it could be why do you think nikki
will like your dish or like you based on
your dish better than the other guys i
marinated that with the love that i want
to like portray through the dish right
this is really a stretch now
like marinating like the onions the
garlic leaving things overnight and just
letting like your thoughts simmer mr
complex exactly so if she tastes it and
doesn't say the word thoughtful i will
be disappointed i mean i will be too
fire away oh there's rice
while she's blushing oh what was that i
need to eat are you in pain are you okay
she's taking it all in
she's in love already i just need to
finish chewing before i say something
i'm not sure if he marinated the meat
but he marinated it overnight really
oh damn
well maybe it needs a little bit more
soy sauce or something oh no man i feel
so bad i don't want to roast them no
they have signed away their rights to
their self-esteem please obliterate them
we did where did it say that in the
contract it was in the contract wait a
minute so i'm not too sure what kind of
cut meat this is you know i didn't even
know i don't even know it's pretty
tender but i feel like it's a little
overcooked i want to see how it's cooked
actually in the inside he's dissecting
it
cutting it up the meat is fine but it's
just dry a moment of silence
it kind of feels like he just left it in
a pan and forgot about it the onions are
very well cooked so plus points for that
i'll take that i'll take that i'll take
onions onions so would you date this guy
uh
hi my name is
beef i'm dry how attractive do you think
this guy is just based on his dish
honestly because he kind of went low
effort
i feel like he's probably someone who's
like relatively hot there you go that's
okay okay balance balance people who are
attractive generally like don't really
put in as much effort into other people
as much as themselves it's like a new
york times review i'm confused so unless
he's cooking this for himself you know
he's probably somewhat attractive but
the plot twist i like the personality
better so unfortunately
i'm gonna have to look at the other
options before i make the decision i
like her she like yo that was a fully
rounded criticism i'll take that dude
someone called 9-1-1 for a homicide
right here oh my god i like the fact
that he had rice in it
i'm actually pretty confident in my dish
i mean i brought ribs because i mean i
think eating with your hands is pretty
much as filipino as you can get so we
got the pork ribs here uh filipino
barbecue style family secret recipe it's
got like your typical soy sauce you got
banana ketchup you got bay leaves
cardamom black pepper allspice like all
those classic filipino ingredients the
best part about this dish in my opinion
is the gravy that comes with it this is
some scallions so we're going to chop
that up and sprinkle that over the ribs
what do you think it says about what
made it low maintenance that smells so
good and it's so aesthetic it's the
chives it's the green on the brown do
you know what this is called it's like
escaping my mind it's a very unique
exotic and hyper specific dish called
ribs
but is it like a specific marinade i i
don't want to do him dirty because i
don't actually remember what he said
okay okay okay thanks chris
it's specific to how his family makes it
and no one else makes ribs like that i
see okay because it smells so good the
fact that it's all cut up already for me
is he a caring type of person i think
you are man does he like take care of
people no he's an [ __ ] is it really
okay i can't cut it though i think he
specifically said eat with your hands
interesting flavor it tastes like
there's some sort of secret ingredient i
can't tell what it is you're unique man
you're unique unpredictable i know i'm
supposed to find faults in this but i'm
finding it very difficult to find
something wrong with this
so what does this say about him how
attractive do you think he is i feel
like since it's a family recipe he comes
off as like a family man to me did you
just family zone him
is that worse than like friend zone
that's pretty bad
it's pretty bad damn she's gonna come
out and she's gonna be like hey kuya oh
and the fact that you were supposed to
eat this with your hands i feel like he
might be like an outdoor outgoing type
of person wow she's right on there she's
ready it's like she knows you're ready i
am a little bit more of a neater person
though she has to join the wild side oh
work i feel like he would take me hiking
and i'm not really sure i'm down for
that i'm more of a gamer and i like to
stay indoors most of the time do you
think you're compatible at all though i
could get along with him i think if he
opens up a restaurant i'll probably go
oh yo that's pretty sick i got a
customer
revenue the fact that he neatly arranged
a dish and kind of like put it together
in a really really aesthetic way gives
me creative vibes i guess like i don't
know he might be a fellow creative like
me but you can create something lovely
with her i can create a beautiful future
he described himself as low maintenance
low maintenance this is so high effort
though i feel like low maintenance was
like the first guy what what if a guy
just made you one giant bowl of rice
that would be great would you marry him
on the spot i would love that means he
knows me oh she's not gonna like me
because mine doesn't have rice
my dish today is a fusion instead of a
sausage egg and cheese i'm making
longanisa egg and uh garlic aioli wow
you guys are looking pretty nervous
right now yeah that sounded like yeah
man you really had to go right after mr
low maintenance no i'm the one now i'm
the one sweating which parts did you
make from scratch this the panda sauce
and then um i hatch the egg whenever i
cook i like always try to go ham do you
think nicki will find that attractive
possibly hopefully you need something
something different you know we'll see
if that different will get would get her
oh
longanisa on a burger i've never seen
this before did he tell you how i'm
supposed am i supposed to reconstruct it
myself yeah so he wanted to show off the
ingredients and then have you reassemble
it an ikea burger am i supposed to smear
this inside too it didn't come with a
manual okay
i'm dead she ate the garnish
wow that's juicy
the egg just leaked out this tastes
pretty good yes let's go i was a little
oh he used panda saul
i feel like he used like a spin the
wheel type thing put random filipino
ingredients on it and then put something
together oh actually no it sounds like
breakfast yeah yes i think the fact that
he made me a breakfast dish means he's
an early morning person i am a morning
person
i wake up 5 30 in the morning
unfortunately i am usually not awake for
breakfast that's okay you can cook for
her in the morning and get breakfast
breakfast can be lunch sometimes there
was effort in plating it i actually do
enjoy it i would eat this but maybe
without the lettuce and the tomatoes
are garnished
i mean if you're gonna make something
that looks like a burger and you put
sliced tomato and lettuce in the perfect
size she's gonna try to put it in
retrospect you should have put some
instructions it says under the tomato
stop okay the fact that he kind of left
everything out for me to put together
makes me feel like he's the type of
person that if i say i'm cold wouldn't
tell me to like go grab my own jacket
instead of giving me a hand
i feel so mean
how do you get that from him let him
have it that's literally tell him who he
really is that's the vibes that i'm
getting from this that's the complete
opposite that is the type of person
who's just like you know if i see a bug
and i want him to kill it hands me the
slipper and has me do it myself i don't
know i feel like he gives like the bare
minimum he baked the pandas out himself
wait okay now that changes things you
should have told me that from the very
start because i thought wow that's like
a 180 real quick i thought this was kind
of taken off the shelf and then like cut
open no he baked it from scratch
i feel so bad saying all that good i'm
kidding i'm kidding this tastes like it
was from like a bakery i apologize
you're here to say whatever you want and
you apologize i've been humble did he
just gaslight you with his food somehow
i've just been humbled i know when to
admit when i'm wrong
i just like wrecked this guy and then
bam you called him the low effort he
baked to find us off from scratch
so nikki who will you be going on a date
with
[Music]
the second one as much as
this one tasted really good the fact
that i feel like he's a nature type
person kind of puts him probably at the
least likely
for number one it was probably the most
homey i feel like it would be very
relaxing and comfortable to be around
them whereas this person i feel like is
a little bit more exciting honestly the
fact that it's so different it is the
most surprising and i do like that so
i'm gonna go with this guy number three
you ready to meet him yeah all right
nikki come on out
[Music]
hi hello oh hello hello hello how are
you guys i'm geo sam i'm jason nice to
meet you guys nice to meet you too and
she's nikki yes
you selected jason
as the winner do you have anything to
say to everyone overall about today your
food was just still pretty good
just not great but pretty good
okay so in this episode you guys are
actually going to be going on a mini
date and you guys are going to go off
and talk on your own off camera and then
we'll check back in in a bit and see if
you guys want to go on another date on
your own after that sound good all right
cool sounds good wait um wait can you
don't do don't do that you know what to
say don't pull that it's boyfriend
material
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for attending today's ceremony
you may now kiss the bride
hello yeah he left you to put on your
own coat instead of giving you would you
actually give her
dude i told her like i would literally
need you a blanket he sounds like a
keeper yeah he's sweet i'm not salty at
all i'm not upset i'm just happy man i'm
happy for them totally happy for them
man since i'm flying back on monday uh
back to la and he's gonna be around here
we decided we're gonna do a little long
distance e-dating yes and we promised it
right yes so we're going to be playing
valerian together oh you both play
valerie yes sir
and we both suck i guess we make a
great pair
i'm so sorry okay maybe this is a
mistake
[Applause]
you